مدارس وخلت من ضجيج التلاميذ وحركتهم ساحه
هادئه وفصول مغلقه بعد ان رفع المعلمون
شعار تحسين الاجر مقابل العمل
اضراب كان متدرجا ومتذبذبا لكنه دخل الان
الى مرحله جديده بعد ان طلبت بعض المدارس
من تلاميذها اعظم الحضور الى المدرسه بسبب
الاضراب
المطالبه بزياده الراتب 115 دولارا كلها
اسباب واعذار لم تجد طريقها الى الحل
هم بيطالبه
بالصرف على التعليم اعتبار ان هي قضيه بتم
المجتمع بشكل عام انه لابد للدوله ان تضع
ميزانيه 20% من موازنتها للصرف على
التعليم
والمعلمين بيطالبه برده بزياده الحد
الادنى
69% من الحد الادنى
للازمه هنا بعد اخر
المتضررون هم تلاميذ المدارس الحكوميه اثر
خلاف ضل قائما بين المعلمين ووزاره
التربيه والتعليم بسبب ضعف المرتبات كارثه
تنذر بان يخسر التلاميذ عامهم الدراسي
ترسلون نجلاء ابنتها ترتيل الى المدرسه
يوميا دون فائده تذكر اذ اصبحت الام تؤدي
دور المدرسه في التعليم استياء كان واضحا
على اسر عديده يدرس ابنائهم في المدارس
الحكوميه نحن كواصل متضررين من الاضراب
بتاع المعلمين ده فين الطالب يعني العام
الدراسي
في مدارس مدربه مدارس غير مطربه يعني حتى
في الحكومي ذاته
تداعيات استدعت ان تتدخل وزاره التربيه
والتعليم لتعلن عن تعديل التقويم الدراسي
بمنح اجازه تبدا في الحادي عشر من هذا
الشهر وتستمر ثلاثه اسابيع
معالجات يراها البعض تطويل الازمه وهروب
من الحل
فالدراسه في السودان باتت تتعطل للاضراب
والتظاهرات والخريف وبعض الامراض وايضا في
منح الاجازات لن يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم